-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering and applause ]
What a show we have
for you tonight.
From the big summer blockbuster
"Top Gun: Maverick,"
Jon Hamm is my guest tonight!
-Come on!
[ Cheering and applause ]
It is such a treat.
You all get to look
at a tall, handsome,
charming guy.
And also, Jon Hamm is here.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Awesome.
That's right,
"Top Gun: Maverick"
is expected to be
the summer's biggest movie.
It took 36 years
to make the sequel,
so, if it does well enough,
they're going to finish
the trilogy in 2058.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, fingers crossed.
Well, this is exciting --
today, after a two-year hiatus,
Fleet Week returned
to New York City.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Fleet Week.
I love it.
I love it. What's better than
seeing a bunch of Navy SEALs
infiltrate the M&M store?
[ Laughter ]
"I'm going in."
Of course,
Fleet Week kicked off today
with the parade of ships
up the Hudson River.
At first I thought,
"Damn, the marketing
for 'Top Gun' is insane."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Meanwhile, today is also
National Wine Day.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh, yeah!
-Some people celebrated
by slowly pouring a glass,
sniffing, and swirling,
while others stuck a straw
right through the Franzia bag,
like an alcoholic Capri Sun.
[ Laughter ]
But, if wine isn't your thing,
I saw that Miller Lite
is gearing up
for the long weekend
with a brand-new
beer and barbecue combination.
Take a look at this.
-The American Brewing Company
is introducing
Miller Lite Beercoal.
It's the first ever
Miller Lite-infused charcoal.
[ Laughter ]
-It's pretty amazing.
Now, my dad and my charcoal
can both get lit
at the same time.
-Oh.
-It's unbelievable.
Very interesting.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The great thing about charcoal
made from Miller Lite is
that there's enough alcohol
to get a flame going,
but enough water to put it out,
you know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of mashups,
Oreo and Ritz have teamed up
to combine Ritz crackers
and Oreo cookies
into a limited edition snack.
Here, take a look at this.
[ Ewws and ohs ]
[ Laughter ]
Seems kind of weird,
but that's actually not
the strangest snack mashup.
I'll show you what I mean.
For instance, Corn Nuts,
Kashi, and Fritos Chili Cheese
teamed up to create...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up, Chef Boyardee teamed up
with Swedish Fish to create...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally, Doritos teamed up
with Planters to create...
[ Cheering and applause ]
There you go.
That's interesting.
[ Rimshot ]
Interesting combo.
I think it'll work.
Well, as I've mentioned before,
YouTube has a new feature
where you can skip
the boring parts of a video
and cut right to the good part.
And I guess they also have
something similar on TikTok
and we tried it out
with some recent videos
people have posted.
For instance,
if you're watching a video,
you can skip this part...
♪♪
...and go right to this...
[ Laughter ]
Let me give you
one more example.
You can skip this part...
-What's up, [bleep]?
I'll show you how to Wutang.
...and go right to this...
[ Coughs ]
[ Ohs and applause ]
-Whoa! Whoa!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What?!
-I've never seen that.
-Never seen that before
in my life, ever.
Never seen that.
-Oh, my God.
Ooh!
-Guys, some news from overseas.
[ Laughter ]
Some news from overseas --
I saw that Nike is reportedly
leaving Russia permanently.
[ Oohs ]
Yep, Nike is basically the same
in Russia,
except the slogan is...
[ Russian accent ]
[ Laughter ]
Some more news here --
I read that, in an effort
to lower gas prices,
the government is considering
tapping into a rarely used
emergency diesel reserve.
Check out this announcement.
-Yo, it's Vin Diesel,
here to tell you
[ Laughter ]
[ Ethereal "Battle Hymn
of the Republic" plays ]
about the diesel reserve.
The White House is taking care
of our cars
because cars are family
and we'll do anything
for our family,
[ Laughter ]
just like we do anything
for our cars.
We feed our families food
like we feed our cars gas.
Opening the tank is like
opening your mouth
and putting gas in is like food.
[ Laughter ]
Think about different people
in your family.
Some eat premium,
but others eat unleaded.
[ Laughter ]
And the gas station
is kind of like
a car's Olive Garden.
[ Laughter ]
And you know what they say
at Olive Garden...
[ Laughter ]
Fill up and leave.
-Interesting, right?
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, this is going viral --
a raccoon in California
is doing fine
after it got stuck in a roof.
Check this out.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
Even worse, the ceiling fan
kept smacking it in the face.
It's like, "Ouch, ouch,
ouch, ouch, ouch."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it looks like somebody
went a little too hard
for National Wine Day.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I heard about a couple
with a busy life
who just got married
after a 60-year engagement.
[ Ohs and laughter ]
Sixty years.
That explains why one
of the gifts on the registry
was a new hip.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It really is a sweet story.
They actually met on the show
"22,000 Day Fiancé."
[ Laughter ]
It was really cute.
It's awesome.